[Music]
great
what's uh fair price for that village
200
i just need that village cleared today
all right if they refuse
cut their tongues out
red notices have been issued for the
notorious black swans a family-owned
private military company linked to
alleged atrocities in the republic of
georgia
the sas is about to move on us to
confirm this is a hard arrest you'll
serve the red notice
race is special everyone is replaceable
race isn't dead boss
[Music]
i love being with you tom i don't
understand you
let's talk about this in paris haven't
said yes yet don't be late
[Music]
major breaking news the eurostream train
has been hijacked
my father taught me all about these this
one carries gas to homes across the uk
if you don't pay us i will destroy this
tunnel and
everyone in it if she exposes what we've
done this is a very big problem for me
get down there and kill her
stay
there's a player in the battle space
he's armed and skilled
he's looking for a way into the
carriages
what are you doing
this isn't about money it's revenge
we're more alike than you know
let me help you embrace who you really
are
[Music]
you